a gentleman I just want to start by
reading something actually words that
you may be familiar with the Labour
Party has been my life but I've had to
be honest and the truth is that I've
become ashamed as a Labour Party on the
Jeremy Corbyn he spent his entire career
supporting extremists in some cases
including terrorists and anti-semites
these are the words of in Austin who
until today was a Labour MP how does
that make you feel I'm very sorry that
Ian's resigned to Labour Party and I'm
very sorry he uses language like that he
and I have known each other a very long
time we've both been in Parliament
together
I'm not saying we've always agreed on
Iraq war or many other issues we didn't
but I don't think it's helpful to use
language like that I've spent my life on
human rights on peace and trying to
bring people together and that is how I
tried to why are you little bit members
the public might hear statements like
that and statements that he's also made
saying that I always tell the truth I
could never ask me local people to make
Jeremy Corbyn Prime Minister because he
and John McDonald you'll show their
Chancellor cannot be trusted does it why
are you at all the public might think
this man has known Jeremy Corbyn for a
long time maybe I should listen to him
well lots of other people have known me
for even longer and would have a very
different view than here in Austin in
Austin was elected as a Labour MP in
June 2017 on exactly the same manifesto
as I was elected for the many not the
few that manifesto promise to do
everything we could to end austerity to
reduce to power and wealth in our
society to end the grotesque
inequalities that our own Britain that
is the core value of the Labor Party and
I'm sure he him underneath it actually
shares that core value Chris Williamson
close I love you all says that he thinks
that here in Austin talk about him being
elected under the labor manifesto which
you stood on as well says that he was
elected under the election under false
pretenses you think he's got point let's
move on from this in was elected I was
elected Chris was elected all on the
same manifesto ian has decided
sadly to leave the label
because it's not just mr. utterson oh is
it mr. Gordon because I mean if we just
look through some mistakes just this
week from any of your boil up former
parliamentary colleagues Luciana Burgess
saying that she'd become embarrassed and
ashamed remain in the labour party
Gavin shuka the Labour Party is riddled
with anti-semitism Jeremy Corbyn
presents a threat to our national
security
Joan coffee any criticism of the
leadership is responded to with abuse
and accusations of treachery does this
not make you angry I'm sorry I think the
last part is complete nonsense people
criticise me as they criticise everybody
else that is public life that is
politics I understand that I accept that
criticism I take that criticism that's
we're about but fundamentally why are we
in public life are we elected there for
ourselves or elected there because we're
trying to change the way our society is
so that we do reduce the levels of
inequality and poverty improvement
a part of your party these aren't
conservatives who are saying that you're
a threat to national security
these are members of your own party what
did you think they're saying this well
going that low today I have decided to
resign from the party and form their own
group I think that they owe it to the
people that elected them in the first
place that perhaps they should put their
their offer back to the people in those
decisions you have a mileage to decide
whether they want to be the MP or not
they were elected on the same manifesto
as me
well it's interesting in Justin on that
point back in 2011 you treated in our
electoral system you vote for an MP
rather than the party or leader so
what's changed since then you weren't
calling for you to vote for an imperial
physician C but their MP stands on a on
a manifesto wish but given that you said
in 2010 that you vote for an MP then
there's no need up election is that
really you do vote for an MP when that
MP puts forward a proposal a program to
their constituents and the constituents
protocol do you want your MPs many of
whom are now saying there needs to be
changes from the leadership you know
just Philips for example still for the
moment at least in the labour party so
look you keep saying this hang on a
minute there's a lot of Labour MPs and
there's half a million Labour Party
members those party members keep the
party going raise the funds knock on
doors deliver the leaflets they're
people whose voice must be heard as well
and you haven't quoted them but you know
it's but you know well as noted and
these are important up there they're
important of course it appears like
they're not and they're saying no but
they're saying that you're a threat to
national security so it's not surprising
if people listen just just well it's
still a Labour MP says at the moment if
you're not in his gang it feels as if
you have no role in the party do you
think that looking back maybe
some of this your fault is any of this
your fault you could have perhaps
believed that they made a rational
decision to resign to the party
informant an independent group I spend a
great deal of time talking to a lot of
people in the party many of whom offer
me advice some of its very detailed some
of it very critical but they offer
advice and Emerson do you have any
regrets at all regrets regrets about
your personal conduct
until you enjoy that business and became
great at this party to expand the
membership to make sure what a
campaigning party to get a community
organizing unit going so a more active
and presently the communities in get
outside ready for anyway did you try and
persuade them to stay I want them to
stay and you try and persuade them to
listen none of them contacted me before
they resigned I first heard of the all
new names that I would have given them a
real look to say please come on in
we're old friend we spoke to a number of
people person
did you deduce any other people did I go
through a listing call them all up I
didn't know who was going to resign
because none of them had the code have
you made any have you made any attempt
to speak 20mp so it's still in the party
yes so reach out and say sometimes great
recipes all the time I'm in Parliament
every week season never no regrets of
being an MP is a great privilege and a
great honor but it's also a great
responsibility to be true to the values
that we put you one thing you will put
to the electorate for you ruler one
thing you could do is say you know what
I think this is a moment for the whole
party to come together I don't want
anyone else to leave so I'm gonna go
shuffle the shadows how that goes no I'm
not going to appoint a shadow camera
because you on Sky News tell me - no
it's not me just Philip Shaw and piers
said she thinks it would be a really
good idea if you open up the Shadow
Cabinet to other wings of the party is
that something you'd be willing to
consider the shadow cabinet has always
been
select in 2015 I appointed a Shadow
Cabinet some of whom resigned a few
months later and there are various
opinions around the shadow cabinet table
that they have a ulterior motive these
people if you think the deal or I let me
put it another way gee do you think
never accepted your leadership really I
think those are questions you need to
put to them what do you think that you
put those questions to them not me my
job is to leave departed my job is to
take the stories up with them and that
is what we did earlier in the week force
from your office briefed that the
independent group is now of course not a
member but the others independent group
they're now sitting with Tory's part
vitória establishment coalition do you
think that maybe some of these people
were closer to the Tory party than the
world yours part of the labor but they
haven't yet put out any coherent policy
statements all I've heard his economic
message from Chris Leslie which with
which I do not agree because he seems to
be completely at variance with our anti
austerity program and I can't accept
that
do you think it might be best in the
long run if it isn't maybe they don't
really agree with you and the sort of
party you now are maybe it's best if
they do leave people like this up with
these views do you think so maybe it
when he has made the decision I did not
want anyone to leave I do not want
anything I want our party to be strong
to be broad and inclusive I've been in
the labor party all my life I joined
when I was 16
and it's always been a very broad church
in which case would you welcome them
back well they show no signs of wanting
to cover their babies so we designed a
week ago I said a bit of a change of
heart
Jeremy I'd really like to come back
Philip Hammond had said that the three
Tories are very welcome to come back to
the Tory party nobody's approached me
with any change and if these beings
listen I'm not speculating honest I'd
say that's a no I think and in terms of
more generally you don't necessarily
obviously agree with the comments that
these MPs have made horse Tom Watson
your own deputy has talked to said that
he doesn't recognise the Labour Party
anymore he says the harshness the
brutality the bullying is he right
listen there is no place for harshness
bullying or anything else in the party
I'm telling the truth
I don't believe it exists on a wide
scale where there is bad behavior we
deal with where there is a problem we
deal
that's why why does Tom Watson say that
it does I you'd have to ask Tom Watson
that and I was speaking to Tom Watson in
very near future okay you're unhappy
with what he's had to say look he's made
a comment
it's his comment not mine you disagree
with him well of course I disagree with
him because I do not wish to be in a
party there was an important so what's
his motive for saying then ask him not
me because I want us to talk about the
issues that people face and your
question so and I assure you they will I
just answer any righteous I just I just
want to just clear a couple of what so
if I understand what is life outside
Western well well but these enemies are
important are they and they say they've
been abused by your supporters so that's
sort of much less course MPs report but
we are sent there for a reason
yes and if I may say so you and your
splendid colleagues in the media
only ever talked about Westminster
gossip you never ever talk about what's
happening outside all doing gossip when
your own MP's the biggest split the
label parts it's not a great one but
least leave that team that to one side
just on what Tom Watson said he also
said that Luciana Burgess specifically
was driven out by racist bullies you
agree she was driven out by racist good
I spoke to Luciana very briefly last
week to wish her well because she's
expecting a baby and the cases that have
been abuse that she suffered from the
anti-semitic abuse she suffered from her
absolutely dreadful legal action has
been taken by her and others and we have
taken action to discipline people that
have committed and any anti-semitic acts
in relation to her or indeed to anybody
else and I'm very sorry but the way
Luciana has been targeted my auntie
serious did you at any point other than
from which I were with her baby did you
any points over the last few weeks and
months reach out to her to offer your
personal support and we thought the
reasons we do offer support to all those
that suffering and usually reached out
cam can we just get make it clear we
don't accept anti-semitism in any form
in our party I understand but you all
just be let's be very clear understand I
turn them like that but you are as is
you often say yourself and is well known
you are a anti racism campaign you have
been so for all your political life
given that one of your MPs that was the
victim of racism repeatedly on your own
it would be of interest to know whether
at any point you reached out to discuss
that matter with her recently we've had
discussions with her over the last year
benezia hue haven't we said I spoke to
her briefly last week that was the last
time I spoke to her that was and she's
now resigned and I really regret her
resignation my job's done wise people
might find it odd that with a case on
anti-semitism in the labour party the
chair of the Jewish labor movement
repeatedly talking about that publicly
don't and why people might think that
you don't necessarily as concerns you
want to be you haven't you haven't
referred to the very many other people
in the Jewish community that do say they
are pleased with the actions the party
has taken in its compliance unit in the
Chakrabarti inquiry and the report that
came from it and the disciplinary action
suspensions that have been taken you
never mention any of that if an MP well
you know you don't
okay fine if you want to talk about what
other day about you we can you don't
even Jewish MP says you don't care about
the issue Jewish Board of Deputies says
you swim in a sewer of anti-semitism in
austen whose father fled the Nazi says
the hard truth is the party's tough on
the people complaining about
anti-semitism and it is on the
anti-semites Frank field formerly a
Labour MP says you because your party's
become a force for anti-semitism in
British politics the chief rabbi of the
United Kingdom says that the remarks you
have made in the past are the most
offensive than any politician since the
river of blood and Enoch Powell so
really where you can be you can
understand me you're Jewish and being at
the chief rabbi can all say one thing
you're saying another just and where the
public might think maybe I'm gonna
believe them a lot you speak to the very
large number of rabbis that signed a
letter in support of the actions we were
taken look at the letter in The Guardian
two days ago supporting the actions
we've taken look at the views of many
people across the country that recognize
racism is at
scourge in any form whatsoever I want to
go all including of course on December 2
one of your allies lemma clusky says
that he thinks that the issue of
anti-semitism is being contrived do you
know limit anti-semitism does exist
within our society it has to be driven
out and it's on the rise in Europe it's
also worse in some cases in some
countries in Europe particularly the
levels of Holocaust in our in Poland and
other places I do think we have to be
realistic and serious about the jamun
Jim Adamic Dolan said today that the
party needs to move quicker and faster
you agree with that we do it as quickly
as we can but there has to be fairness
involved with it there has to be justice
involved in it as well so you have to
collect the evidence and then take a
decision on the basis of the evidence
you can't just have a knee-jerk reaction
to everything just very tailored respond
on brexit your show the Chancellor John
McDonnell has also said today that he's
moving towards the parties moving more
quickly towards and a people's vote do
you agree with that is that your part is
personal
I've been in Brussels yesterday in
Madrid Madrid today we have made it to
the European Commission yesterday and
that meet those meetings were all about
the danger of a No Deal exit from the
European Union and this afternoon I just
had a meeting with British residents in
Spain are also concerned about it No
Deal exit that would be a catastrophic
position so we put forward what I
believe to be a credible plan which is
of a customs union access to the single
market and protection of the rights that
we've obtained work and so on from the
European Union and that at a later stage
when there's been a negotiation around
that that's a consideration to put to a
public vote so we've moved a long way on
this on the customs union and so on and
actually the reception we've had has
been very positive
not all agreed but it's been a positive
but the disaster of a No Deal exit would
be serious but there's been this one
idea performed by one of our enemies
that potentially the Prime Minister you
could give the Prime Minister her votes
for the deal on the basis that it might
then will then be put to a referendum
with
on that basis is that something that you
need feels I can't see how one could
support her deal her deal is very badly
flawed and very damaging to the
interests of our country and the people
so no referendum on the proposed deal I
think we need to put forward the
alternative we have which is what we
could do would you put forward a labor
deal to the public that's exactly what I
just talked about the the labor offer is
of the three things they say and we
consider putting out to the public you
consider putting the labor deal to the
block that's the point we're discussing
now in the party okay and just like with
what came out of our conference our
conference decision was emphatically
that no deal should we take it off the
table the problem is is the prime
minister who's irresponsibly running
down the clock irresponsibly running
down the clock between her Deal and No
Deal well that is not the choice the
choice is a credible deal with the
European Union or her deal which is
damaging to the interests of people of
dysfunction and just finally some of
your MPs speculating about the future
future of the party just want to do just
to show you assure everyone you're gonna
be around for the next election I think
in 2022 I'm very proud to lead the Labor
Party I'm very proud of the increasing
membership we've got I'm very proud to
campaign on behalf of the party because
it's the Labour strategy jobs economy
environment housing health education
that inspires hope and optimism
and that's what we'll be putting the
electric whenever the election comes
with you as leader any other act with
you is lead and I'm around to go with
yours lead of course